Hi everyone! It seems you guys were big fans
of our 2 other Movie Secrets videos where
we explored amazing facts about your favorite
films! We decided to make this a series to
help quench your thirst for movie knowledge!
So sit back, relax and enjoy Screen Rant’s
Know Your Movies: 20 Amazing Movie Secrets
That Will Blow Your Mind #3.
Mad Max: Fury Road
Actor Hugh Keays-Byrne had his face hidden
behind a mask as the villain of the Mad Max
reboot, but audiences were originally going
to see him play a superhero of a million faces,
as the Martian Manhunter in director George
Miller's cancelled DC Comics team-up, Justice
League Mortal.
For editing Fury Road, George Miller turned
to his wife, editor Margaret Sixel, claiming
that if a man did it, it would look like every
other action movie. What she didn't know was
that he had filmed over 480 hours of film
in the desert, which took a full three months
just to watch it all.
Star Wars: The Force Awakens
Batman Vs Superman director Zack Snyder took
plenty of shots at director JJ Abrams' Star
Wars reboot, while both movies filmed at the
same time. But Abrams got the last laugh,
including a scale model of Batman's Tumbler
Batmobile on the outer hull of the Millennium
Falcon.
To keep his mind off of Star Wars when he
wasn’t filming, JJ Abrams took in the Broadway
musical “Hamilton”. When meeting the musical’s
creator Lin-Manuel Miranda backstage, Miranda
told Abrams to call if he needed new cantina
music. When it came time to record, Abrams
made good on the offer, sharing vocals with
Miranda in the finished song.
Jurassic World
There's no Jurassic Park without John Hammond,
so director Colin Trevorrow made sure to add
a bronze statue of the park creator in his
big-budget sequel. It was assumed Hammond
would have died prior to the movie, but when
actor Richard Attenborough passed away before
release, the statue became a memorial to the
man, not the character.
The stars of the original movie are mostly
left out of Jurassic World, but the return
of 'Mr. DNA' was total fan service. The director,
a huge fan of the original, even recorded
his impression of the late voice actor Greg
Burson for a temporary track. The impression
was so good, the audio team just left it in
as is.
Frozen
Jennifer Lee was the first woman to direct
a Disney movie, and given Frozen's success,
she picked the right one. But fans probably
don't know that she also lent her voice to
the movie, playing Elsa’s mother, the Queen
of Arendelle.
The Avengers: Age of Ultron
Fans of Marvel's heroes were probably too
distracted to notice the subtle war being
fought between the team's two leaders. The
official posters were split between putting
Iron Man front and center, or Captain America
- a major hint at the conflict and Civil War
coming years later.
Captain America: The Winter Soldier
No fan will forget the scene in which Cap
takes down an elevator filled with SHIELD
personnel. What makes it even more impressive
is that it was thefirst scene shotfor
the sequel, setting the stage for the gritty,
hard-hitting follow-up story fans couldn't
get enough of.
The Lego Movie
The directors of this toy adventure relied
on CG to bring the LEGO to life, but also
used a ton of the real thing. Benny the Space
Guy is only in the movie since director Chris
Miller played with him when he was little
- in fact, his actual space set is used in
the film.
Guardians of the Galaxy
Marvel's shared universe means plenty of cameos
from the same actors, but there's at least
one problem. How is it that the young girl
looking for Captain America's autograph is
played by the same woman as Star-Lord's dying
mother more than forty years later? Actress
Laura Haddock plays both, but is almost unrecognizable
on her deathbed.
It's hard to keep the tears back when Peter
Quill reads the final note from his mother,
and was even harder for Pratt. The actress
had to quickly record the voiceover in the
back of a car, just so Pratt could listen
to it during the actual scene, and truly sell
the connection and flood of memories.
Fans had some nitpicking to do when Star-Lord
and Gamora float through space without any
injuries. But the filmmakers actually worked
with NASA on the science of the scene, learning
that humans could survive just as long as
the characters, without serious health problems.
It turns out the movie is science fact, not
fiction.
X-Men Days of Future Past
Surprisingly, Wolverine wasn't planned to
show his bare backside when he arrives in
the past of 1973. But on the day of the shoot,
Jackman told the director that if he were
waking up to a beautiful woman, he wouldn't
be wearing underwear. Everyone was convinced,
blurring the line on whether he's playing
himself, or Wolverine in that particular moment.
It's never explicitly stated, but it's implied
that Quicksilver is the son of Magneto, just
as he was in the X-Men comics. Most fans accepted
the idea immediately... Probably not realizing
that the on screen father and son, Michael
Fassbender and Evan Peters, are less than
ten years apart in age. Who knew?
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
The rebooted Turtles may be mutant cg creations,
but the designers turned to real life actors
who summed up their personalities. Leonardo's
face was based on Russell Crowe, Raphael on
Clint Eastwood, Donatello on Leonard Nimoy,
and Michelangelo on Bill Murray. Fans can
decide how close they came.
Man of Steel
Knowing that moviegoers always assume a superhero's
costume exaggerates the actor's muscles, Zack
Snyder and Henry Cavill wanted to prove their
Superman was something different. Cavill refused
steroids to help him build muscle before his
shirtless scenes, dropping his body fat to
the levels of professional bodybuilders - just
7%. The results... speak for themselves.
Gravity
Nearly every part of this space survival story
was created in a computer, but that only gave
the crew a chance at an incredible joke. At
some points in the movie, reflections of a
camera man or boom mic appear in the astronauts’
helmets, as if they were mistakes that slipped
through editing. Instead, they were put there
by the animators as an inside joke most viewers
will never notice.
Batman V Superman: Dawn Of Justice
The workout demands for the Justice League
lead-in swung for the fences, with Henry Civil
packing on TWICE the muscle of Man of Steel.
Not to be outdone, the physically larger Affleck
made sure to gain thirty pounds of muscle
- and drop to just 8% body fat to make sure
Batman was every hit as intimidating, even
without heat vision.
Captain America: Civil War
The movie's not even here, but one of its
most iconic shots has already been revealed.
And it's not fiction, either: The directors
had star Chris Evans actually suspended between
a crane and helicopter, using his very real
muscles to hold them together. Cg isn't always
the answer, apparently.
Those are some of our favorite mind blowing
movie facts, but let us know which ones we
missed and stay tuned for more! And remember
to subscribe to our channel for more videos
like this one.